[Music]
welcome back everybody i checked in with
john barr over at findlay toyota to see
what's new for 2021 and the minivan just
got
really cool check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
wait john hey ryan how are you i'm
coming to visit you for the new year and
you're already leaving
i'm glad you came to visit and obviously
i'm leaving actually i'm test driving
okay okay what are we in what are we
using this is the brand new 2021
sienna van hybrid latest technology
going to be a big big hit i'm sure well
i love it it looks really nice now it is
20 21 though
it is a 2021 so i feel like i got to
test you on your game
oh really yeah you still know how to
sell me a car i think i do i think i do
you know but the good news is
i've got somebody that's going to
actually tell you all you guys mean
today hey
i'm good i'm good he will help you chris
and then at the end of all i'll talk to
you about
the numbers if you're interested all
right you're here to finish the job
yes i am all right sell me this car well
thank you for coming in rocky
this right here is the completely
redesigned 2021 xsc hybrid
sienna the best way to get a feel for it
is have a seat
oh take a look inside okay see how you
like it
okay oh my gosh wow this is beautiful
very beautiful best way to get a feel
for it take it for a spin
see how it feels okay and then i'll go
over everything after with you okay
[Applause]
wow for such a big car this was a really
smooth ride
well the 2021 sienna comes in
exclusively hybrid
models okay we like the sound of that
it's going to come in a 2.5 liter
four-cylinder engine
with additional two electric motors in
this car very smooth
can take you everywhere but for less
money correct so it also comes in an
all-wheel drive option as well so if you
did want to go out and you know the
wilderness you could do that as well we
need that here in nevada
and tell me about all the bells and
whistles in here because this is high
tech yes so first off it's going to come
with all your new safety features okay
it's called the toyota safety sense
it's going to come with your
pre-collision system it's going to come
with your lane departure assistance
it's going to come with your adaptive
cruise control blind spot monitors rear
cross traffic alert as well as sonar
parking sensors on this vehicle so it's
going to be a super safe and reliable
car for your family
so obviously a family vehicle when i've
got the kids in the back
husband and the passenger seat how do i
entertain them well rocky
this car is going to come with your
bluetooth it's going to come with your
apple carplay it's going to come with
your android auto
you can play whatever music or videos
they like and have all that going
as well as this infotainment system is
going to come with built-in dynamic
navigation so wherever you guys need to
go toyota is going to help you get there
as far as uh climate you're going to
have a dual climate system in here
so you and the hubby can have two
different temperatures you're going to
have your heated seats up front so
you know during the winter when it gets
chilly with the leather you're going to
be able to you know
get in nice and warm in there so
whatever you guys need it's going to
have
wow okay chris well you know what john's
all done you passed the test
i'm sold well what i'm going to do is
let you go inside and talk to john about
the price
and i'm going to go throw this in the
wash and get it ready for you to take
home all right it's a deal
for more information call findlay toyota
at that number on your screen or just
visit www.finleytoy
las vegas now we'll be right back